what is going on everybody welcome to
the introduction of Python programming
that Nets plus equals one as the name
suggests this is an addition it's an
augmentation to Python programming net
so bottom line if I know a topic I will
teach it for free in both video and text
base tutorial form that's really never
going to change but what is gonna change
with plus equals one if you do choose to
subscribe the subscription cost is five
dollars a month and what you get in
return is first of all no advertisements
that would be kind of silly to serve you
ads so if you're logged into Python
programming net you will get no ads
I cannot conditionally remove ads on the
YouTube videos for you but I can do you
something better I can just give you
video downloads so again if you're a
plus equals one subscriber you can log
into Python program net and download an
entire video series and then watch them
on your own
so no ads at all also people have been
requesting things like questions or
quizzes and challenges alongside the
tutorials so again if your plus equals
one subscriber you're going to start
seeing the addition of questions and
challenges in conjunction to the
tutorials no ads and video downloads so
what that means is like for example a
challenge might be hey try to do XYZ and
if you can't do XYZ here are some hints
maybe at the steps to do XYZ and if you
still can't figure out with the hints
then here's exactly how you would do
step one step two step three and so on
and then for questions it would be
simple questions like how do you do X
and then you know simple ABCD kind of
answer choices and then if you get it
wrong why is it wrong if you get it
right congratulations and some more
reaffirmation zhan why that was the
right choice so if that sounds
interesting to you guys you can head to
Python programming at net slash plus
equals one it's literally the symbols
plus equals and then one and you can
sign up right there you can also see
what's currently available in what it's
coming basically how many quizzes
questions how many challenges per series
I plan to continually add to basically
all of the playlist there I'd really
like to see something like you know 50
to 100 questions per large playlist I
think that would really be helpful to a
lot of people so that's my goal but it's
gonna take a very long time to add that
so if you want to see what it's
currently available
you can go there immediately though
there will be no ads and you can do the
video downloads if for whatever reason a
specific series or something that you
really want is not available you can
email me and I'll make sure it gets up
there but pretty much all the recent
series are there so if you guys have any
questions comments concerns whatever you
can leave them below or you can email me
here so Matt Python program net
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and the
subscriptions and until next time